[Music]
heck are you now it's your turn come on
[Music]
wow you are really cool for a woodpecker
hey this is Zagreb and we didn't give
you permission to use it actually this
is a public road built with government
crumbs and it belongs to everyone so
technically you are correct it is yours
but it's also mine hey you don't get off
that easy
look I don't know what I did to offend
you guys but whatever it is I'll stop of
course you will
you would you busy driving seriously
just your school have an anti-bullying
policy sure does that's exactly why we
got kicked out right John high five as
for you two where were we
[Music]
get ready to go commando that was
awesome
you were no MMA all them nobody messes
with my BFF and by that I mean bringer
of free food
[Music]
that's the flying demon right there
[Music]
[Music]
works
oh boy that's how you do things the
woody
[Music]
the thing that I most go to and I even
hear about the name Woody Woodpecker is
that iconic laughs that crazy lunatic
like straight out of the asylum his
laugh is amazing signature people may
not remember the stories but everyone
recognizes that laughs that's a laugh
that would be recognized anywhere in the
world it's something so familiar it's
like here my mom laughs and you know for
real so again any famous pop song as a
hug Woody's laugh is a hook it gets in
your brain and anybody can do it
the laughs I just yeah
you